15 years ago we all experienced the
exhilarating feeling of reading a holy
original screenplay that felt new and
exciting juno had me hooked from the
very first page and was completely
infused with diablo cody's distinctive
voice it was like and it wasn't unlike
anything i'd ever read before
there were definitely some phrases in
there i had not read before a couple
that come to mind are
your eggo is prego and pork swords
like the nominees in this next category
it was the kind of script that you just
knew had to be brought to life on the
big screen here are the nominees for
original screenplay
belfast written by kenneth grana
[Music]
don't look up screenplay by adam mckay
story by adam mckay and david sirota
king richard written by zac bailey
licorice pizza written by paul thomas
anderson
[Applause]
the worst person in the world written by
s kill folked yellow kim trier
[Applause]
and the oscar goes to
kenneth branagh
this is the first oscar for eight-time
career nominee kenneth branagh
[Music]
over here
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you academy voters i thank you my
fellow nominees i salute you this is a
enormous honor for my family it's a
great tribute
to an amazing city and uh fantastic
people i'm only standing here because of
the incredible support of dame donna
langley brian roberts peter kajowski
fearless leader of focus features of
jason cassidy and their amazing team
uh northern ireland screen our brilliant
uk cast and crew led by tamar thomas
laura berrick and becker kovacic uh this
story is the search for joy and hope in
the face of violence and loss we lost
some people along the way johnny
sessions jim dorn and leia newman we
miss them we love them we will never
forget them and we will never forget
all of those lost in the heartbreaking
heartwarming
human story
of that amazing city of belfast on the
fabulous island of ireland
this means a lot thank you so much
you